they give you a piece of information
right
and this is harder by virtue of the fact
that it's just
algebra really there's a bit of a shift
happening here
but just because that's not a number our
brains kind of do something funny and
think like
i was kind of familiar with this when it
was three over five or five and thirteen
or something like that
this makes us spin out a little bit it
is no more difficult
but you will have to kind of bring
together a lot of the knowledge that
we've developed in the last few lessons
okay
so here's my first suggestion tan theta
plus ninety
okay tends a bit hard to work with okay
because ten itself
is what we call we'll cover this later
in this lesson it's an identity
right it's sine over cos so bringing it
back to that will be helpful so let's do
that
it's sine theta plus 90
on cos theta plus mu
okay so the reason why this is good
is because we're much more familiar with
what's happened with what happens to
sine signing cause
as we shift it back and forth we in fact
looked at some of these exact graphs
earlier um friday monday
we have looked at it in recent times but
it's okay i'm not assuming that you know
exactly what these look like
straight away i pause even after having
with this for a long time
which one is it exactly it's not that
hard to work out first let's just do a
really quick graph
of sine and then we'll do the
appropriate shift right
so here's what psi looks like okay now
it's 90 degrees
it's a plus 90 degrees so what direction
am i going in
left right left so i'm going that way 90
degrees now
there's 90 right so see that point there
where it goes to the top
that should be on the axis so i'm
getting this
okay i've shifted it i recognize that
that's cosine
so i'll slap that on the top
okay now i've got cos of theta plus 9
and i'm just going to repeat the same
process
right eventually you'll start to get to
the point where you don't need to do
this
you can start to do it in here this is
still fairly new to us so here is cos
and again i've shifted 90 degrees to the
left so what's it going to look like
i think that's what we're having right
you can see this crest over here is
moved
this intercept has moved to the origin
so is that okay so what is this thing
it's negative it's minus sign right so
minus sine theta okay now the question
was
can you evaluate what this tan blah blah
blah is in terms of
k right so i've clearly made some
progress here because i have
sine theta and i know what sine theta is
okay so i can substitute that
in a second i might as well go all from
thetas
to all k's all in one fell swoop if i
can okay
so in our previous questions like if i
said to you sine theta
equals three over five and i told you
theta was
well theta two okay let's just go with
that right how would you work out cos
theta what steps would you go through
draw a triangle okay so on the cartesian
plane
in the second quadrant i will draw a
triangle okay and it goes over here
right um there's our related angle for
theta our kind of theta
opposite on hypotenuse there's the
adjacent so
there's cos it's negative four and five
happy all right now i can't do this with
numbers
because i've got algebra but it works
just the same doesn't it
instead of three and five hold on
these are all different now i'm still in
the same quadrant
it's still sign so what numbers and
letters should i put where
suggestions please like and subscribe
yeah
see this is a ratio in disguise isn't it
it's k over one right and that's your
opposite and your hypotenuse
my opposite and my hypotenuse
okay so at this point you can now see by
pythagoras and you don't need to labor
it
that side there is the square root of 1
minus k squared
and this is adjacent over hypotenuse
so now i have cos okay uh one more thing
to note because close is
two in sorry theta is excused and i'm in
the second quadrant that
square root actually has a minus sign
out the front right because i'm going to
the left
of the axis so this should be minus
the square root of one minus k squared
over minus x
you happy with that two minus signs
and i'm home okay so does it make sense
do you agree wait wait you got that what
does it prove
okay so what have i done what have i
done i have changed from one variable
theta
to another one okay at the moment
what's the relevance of that we're sort
of leaning towards
when we're going to have all kinds of
different functions and we want to
translate
in a similar way to why we want to
translate from cause to sign or vice
versa it's like well if i know vertical
movement i can work out horizontal
movement in the same way
this kind of changing of variables will
become very very useful to us later
okay